good morning CL welcome to the morning
toast which today has been rebranded to
the morning Tigs it should be rebranded
to the morning takes every day because
this precious gem of a man is here today
just to make the day a little bit more
precious even though it's gonna be
precious as [ __ ] because we're
interviewing a good chain we're
celebrating our toasted bursary today
it's just a very precious day it's a
precious day and so of course Thea was
here to celebrate it with us yeah I mean
deals really been there from the
beginning and as much as he we couldn't
really bring him in the beginning of the
choice because he was still just a bit
but his second birthday is in two weeks
and I feel like he's really matured a
lot in the last six months and now when
we bring him he's much more relaxed but
he used to really like to avert the show
yeah maybe the show needed a little
divine diversion that's the thing about
diversions
they're always Devine exactly no matter
how you slice him anyway see us here and
I can't believe he's turning - I know
I'm 16 short days because his birthday
is on 4/20 yes that was the first time
his birthday wasn't yeah and someone
made an edit of him with a joint which
is like you put a little inappropriate
very inappropriate for a child yeah well
I feel like he's come so far I'm so
proud of him I love him so much and I
just I don't wanna get emotional but I
just loved Theo more than anything and I
had a very traumatizing CBD induced
dream last night do you do you think
there's the correlation between your new
addiction I would say to CBD and your
son's birthday on 4/20 no no correlation
whatsoever okay so you think but it's
like you're taking CBD and then you're
having dreams about your son who was
born on 4/20 makes you think no it
doesn't actually makes you think cuz CBD
is not hot and instantly learned by the
way CBD is [ __ ] because I took the
same thing you took last night
nothing never felt worse never felt more
terrible yes it could you would just
have a stubborn mind no I would maybe
two more milligrams maybe
but like for your first time taking CBD
or tolerance should be low but what did
you think was gonna happen
relaxed easy sleep Betty nice you wanna
know what happened
another torturous night being me Oh oh
my god you're so dramatic you have a
lovely life look at that little barrette
in your hair it is a nice spirit to
complement a nice life no but you know
falling asleep at night is hard oh my
god I have terrible anxiety about like
the
thirty minutes before you actually fall
asleep like you're just left alone with
your thoughts and that can be really
scary and daunting yeah I don't like it
I don't like it either so I try to watch
like uplifting stuff before bed Real
Housewives but of course the mind always
wanders so yeah I like especially when
I'm with Margo I'm like acutely aware of
like how much harder it is for us to
fall asleep in hotel rooms and I'm just
like talking to Margo keeping her up at
night being like Margo don't you hate
this you know and she's like Claudia
leave me alone honey I'm sleeping yeah
she she's been how did she hear that if
she was asleep she's really be smart
girl like homegirl [ __ ] falls asleep
in two seconds it's so annoying
honestly to make those 30 minutes before
about a little bit better I might start
doing my audible books then where they
speak the book to me right because
that's really relaxing and I think that
you should try it and I think that you
should listen to the Scopes Monkey Trial
because it sounds boring cuz I know that
you'll never read the book never but we
have a chance with an audiobook the
Scopes Monkey Trial the history of the
20th century's most famous court case
America's most famous court case what a
great way to dip into audible for you I
think okay falling asleep yes I'm not
much of a reader with audible you get
access to an unbeatable selection of
audio books including bestsellers
motivation mysteries fillers memoirs and
more audio audible has the largest
selection of audiobooks on planet and
now with audible originals the selection
has gotten even more custom with content
made for members audible members can
choose three titles every month one
audiobook and two audible originals you
can't hear anywhere else
audible members also get access to
exclusive audio fitness programs
exciting go to audible.com slash TMT or
text TMT to 500 500 and listen for a
change
that's audible.com slash TMT or text TMT
to 500 500 and listen for a change
AUD ib le comm slash TMT or text uh TMT
to 500 500 that slogan that's like very
much made for me listen for a change
everyone right and may I suggest the
Scopes Monkey Trial that's all I'll say
about it I'll think about it yeah
anyways
might make sleeping a little more
enjoyable honestly when you're sleeping
with a big furry like hot ball of fire
between your legs there's nothing better
yeah I use a heater as my personal feel
it early use my heating pad like I hold
it like I swallow it yeah it depends
where I'm at if I'm doing it for my
tummy
yeah just they need to make a heating
pad that has like a velcro belt that you
could really put on your Fupa during
your period because like a heating pad
is a perfect formula just for your back
but people use it on their neck on their
stomach on their legs and there needs to
be like a Velcro type situation
that's my sharked a convention where
like you should really have like a belt
you can put under your clothes and just
wear around the day when you have your
period that sounds incredible because I
had like earth-shattering cramps the
other day there's nothing worse the
worse they've been in a while and I
literally just and I took my doll which
has caffeine in it and it was my doll
does it was early in the day and I just
laid on my stomach on my heating pad and
I fell asleep for an hour by the time I
woke up the Mitel have kicked in it was
it was nice there's just like so many
fake remedies around cramps and like
actually none of them work except for
like Advil might might all heating pad
heating pad is good but it's temporary
relief you know yeah but it's relief
nonetheless right and when you're
critical heating pad is sit on the
toilet yeah even though like nothing's
coming out no but it's like uh the act
of it we used to like put our legs up
against the wall that didn't work either
but that works for our little baby
cramps yeah never women now we have a
women's cramps my doll don't text toast
anywhere yeah god forbid I bet you know
if you're listening mean idle for your
podcasters if you're hearing a bit of a
crunch in the audio please notice that
Theo is enjoying a delicious chew and
only we were getting him to relax so
just stop complaining if you're already
are if you were thinking about writing a
comment on my review stop right there do
you like my shoes I do or they Erica
Jane X ShoeDazzle
they are sweetly swanky you're gonna
wear them to meet her up says yes of
course because like I said what we can
talk to her about um well we have to put
up a guest card will literally oysters
and I have a lot of questions because I
did read her book and so I just want her
to know that I read her book you know
I'm like a brown-nosing student like
totally I did the reading you're a
stinky brown noser with a hidden agenda
except my Jenna's not so hidden it's
just to impress her right
okay that's a good agenda right that's
just my life's agenda impress people I'm
so excited to just like be in her
presence I know what's gonna be I'm
gonna ask her who she really thinks
leaked the article because now there's a
bunch of conspiracy theory that's that
maybe it was written up maybe it was
pique hmm I don't know more like John
said Sir John Blizzard because when you
sell the story at the tabloids like
their Lisa Vanderpump that's chump
change but for a 24 year old living in
West Hollywood like that might be rent
that's true um also when Lisa Vanderpump
said that she's never sold a story to a
tabloid and she likes wear it on her
children one it's like why should be
starting on her children and to it she
definitely never had sold his story to
its have would she doesn't do it for
money no she does it for yes she doesn't
need a not win or she might not have
ever sold a story but someone she knows
might have sold the story I can't ever
think of john blizzard and john says
that without saying john says john
blizzard john 3:16
what the hell's on that keith urban song
it's John Cougar John Deere John 3:16
ago John Thurman was singing about
John's house I don't know incredibly
committee it's like all the Johnson is
like John Cougar Mellencamp oh shut up
John Deere that his tractor John 3:16
the Bible those are his big what
inspiring lyrics but for Ferb that
really Hills fans John Blizzard John
says so John 3:6
I like that speech I will still use a
little prayer yeah well speaking of
Keith Urban his wife you know Nicole
Kidman is considered a suppressed person
by the scientology department and
scientology is actually headquartered in
clearwater florida where i'm gonna be
this weekend doing shows that in orlando
tickets are going fast so head over to
girls no job calm nice yeah also i like
I would never swear on something so
serious because it's like what if one
time like I blacked out and I did it or
what if you're the beneath him you
forgot that I did actually sell story of
the time right and Lisa Vanderpump she's
getting up there in years like she might
have actually done it and forgotten
right I just think that's such a brave
thing to do almost too brave what are
you trying to prove
yeah no I think like a last resort
because I'm fingers crossed behind of
course she's biting her tongue I really
like desperate act and just like when
you've last resort is swearing on your
children's life like nothing is that
important to like ever do now I would
never swear him deals life even if I was
telling the truth right it probably
wasn't telling the truth it's like
nobody Lisa I swear on my jaw that's a
good meme I like that thanks way to make
it okay you're the meadmaker sure let me
just add it to list of things I'm doing
for
today our taxes your taxes I'm doing my
taxes I'm doing this taxes oh really
then why am I still doing taxes because
we have to file individually and also as
a company Jackie this is a company I
know this is like you know maybe your
first business woman special and it is
mine as well but I'm taking it very
seriously I have to do the taxes you
have to do your taxes no I don't I have
to do the company's taxes I already did
mine my no I'm not okay then I guess I'm
sorry do my taxes I guess I don't have
to do my taxes Chucky's just because the
company's doing taxes doesn't mean you
don't have to do taxes but I'm doing
taxes from the company you are yeah like
from my part in the company oh right so
your pay are doing your part in the
company and then I'm also doing the
company look at this email my Clips here
look at this cool I'm not gonna read
that right now okay I'm doing it I'm
going through the bank statements and
it's shorter so can you make the mean oh
no anyways I'm butterball I know is if
we want to meet the Mike the Imam sick
oh so last night we went to dinner for
Ben's birthday I had a pressed
restaurant which was nice and all but
what was really exciting was that we got
to meet French camber she showed up I
don't know who invited her but she was a
welcome addition but speaking of people
we actually did get to meet and not meet
I just mean like see was an Olsen twin
right which one that was special I'm
very unclear I think with Ashley but
still special nonetheless right I was
gonna ask her what she thought about am
Becky you see Lori Loughlin autograph
signing autographs outside Court good
for her she looked she lost a lot of
weight too she wants me going through a
hard time maybe we should go to jail
totally that's like right what we need
to just get the last five pounds right
was like the hardest lose last ten
whatever Wow
do you say I only have 5 ounces it's so
nice right it's like once you lose
weight it's like just getting to the
finish line and I think the only thing I
could really do that is like a little
jail time I feel like I'm actually
really happy with where I'm at I do feel
like my chin is growing back like to the
original place that I was at which is
really upsetting but otherwise I can't
keep that man down I've got a thigh
muscle a cosmopolitan
he can't be kept down no he literally
has international travel to embark on
he's a passport he's the boy he's got it
literally there yeah I feel I'm feeling
pretty good
he teased me fringe can't bear it's just
honestly so hearts like go on with my
day being professional hosting a morning
show when there
literally like the most precious gem of
a man like laying at my feet just like
begging for my attention I know but
he'll be there splitting in front of us
you know is that what it's called yeah
when they like split their legs like
late with their drunk on the floor I
like that it's called I thought the
technical term was Baretta and that's
actually the medical term but us
layman's we just say split split okay
that's like I'm from wholes the split
that they drink oh yeah it was called
something anyone spooge blue Josh yeah
oh man I don't think I move in so long
what a weird movie he'll rise in such a
weird movie it's like Lee Teuk you
mented the rise and fall of one Shia
LaBeouf oh and let's me not forget the
iconic presence of oh [ __ ] what's her
name
just give me a second Tojo get it
Sigourney Weaver oh it's an iconic
present it truly is sing Gorney Weaver
Sigourney Weaver is also on the
commercial playing in New York these
days
about the Botanical Garden there's like
a flower show at the New York Botanical
Garden and the commercial starts hey
it's me Sigourney Weaver is that weird
maybe we should go to the Botanical
Garden I know support her latest efforts
I actually love the Botanical Garden I
was gonna get married there I know you
are but then but then it was just like
too hot like too much outdoor space
actually no what happened was we went
the tour we loved it but they're like
food is jizz sploosh is the drink from
holes yes sploosh very true and back to
the Botanical Garden I was gonna do it
but there rain alternative they're like
if it rains or if we see a cloud like we
have to move everything inside and the
inside portion was actually like a rec
hall gym and I just wasn't ready to take
the risk of like maybe they're being
rained in September understood it's like
Rea game on your wedding day okay I
think are you ready I think I'm ready
because we have to go get ready for
Erica Jane so let's get on with the show
here are the fast five stories that you
need to know before you wake up and take
a bite out of your morning toast okay
first up big story of the day everyone's
talking about it Britney Spears checks
into a mental health facility amid her
dad's illness I really feel like this is
for the best
me too Britney Spears has been admitted
to a mental health facility the pop star
is receiving treatment amid her struggle
to cope with her dad's declining health
quote Britney was having a hard time
healing with her dad's health issues
Britney hasn't been drinking or doing
drugs or anything
she just has some very difficult
emotional and mental health issues she's
got a way to try to deal with her issues
before they get worse a source close to
the sphere's family told page six on
Wednesday quote she has recently been
showing signs of being under a lot of
strain our source added before pointing
out that Jamie is quote the support in
her life it's very confusing as a dad
and the sisters names are both Janey oh
my god okay then they've been realized
once Jamie and Lynne and one Jamie and
one's a toaster and ones not right the
weird thing about this entire story is
that one Jamie Lynn Spears has a toaster
- no - II hate him - is that Jamie Lynn
is like the most normal life ever
rightly she just like lives in Louisiana
like ghost [ __ ] t-ball practice with the
kids just had another baby I was like
the cutest husband like she's just like
out here living life and I really feel
like this going
Britany going to this facility is like
the greatest thing like she's been
working to the bone since she was 18 and
like homegirl needs a break I feel like
this is where Ariana Grande's gonna be
if she doesn't take a nap in the next
like five or 10 years like Britney needs
a break I'm glad her tour is over in
Vegas she needs some alone time and she
just needs to chill agreed what's
interesting is that on E online homepage
Story number one Jamie Lynn Spears is
private world since leaving Hollywood is
impressive oh that's what we said
everyone agrees and Story number three
is about Britney Spears is going to a
mental position Wow more is it is it
2011 because the Spears's are just
taking over the headlines right and it's
like wow more people are interested in
positive stories yeah no I mean I'm
obviously devastated that I never got to
see Britney in Vegas but I'm okay with
it just knowing that she's hopefully
gonna just relax
I hope wherever she goes they just let
her sleep and like take long walks and
like drink chamomile tea and just like
cash her checks in peace like she
doesn't need to keep working she's a
long catalog a long history alone right
she could be licensing her songs to
commercials and just sit back and relax
she has her fragrances right
she needs a line of Kmart and she's good
yeah let's work on that for her I love
that for her cool thing you and me just
like a circus huh huh okay
next step speaking me wait one more time
remember when she came out with that
song if you seek Amy and it was like the
craziest thing we're people were like
you got it you got it and I'm like what
do you get if you seek Amy and like who
the [ __ ] is Amy if you seek Amy got it
craziness just please remember when she
came out at the VMAs and like she had
like the smallest tummy ever and like
the world was shook to the course she
was singing it's Britney [ __ ] song I'll
show you a picture I've literally would
nowadays like that [ __ ] we never fight
she was such a pioneer for so much of
the brunt of societies that's so true
Britney Spears and BM a well that's
gonna come up as when she made out with
Madonna no I'm a slave for once this
song it's Britney [ __ ] you better work
[ __ ] you better work [ __ ] I think ima
belly okay but all you're gonna find is
either the snake or Madonna nope
first up oh my god you're bad she would
look so cute like [ __ ] that she is she
looks great
totally everyone's crazy and everyone so
quick to be so mean totally but I feel
like she really has no idea like what
people say about her she's very
disconnected in a good way yeah from
like Instagram yeah his films those
little videos with her tiny furniture
and has someone else post them I don't I
don't follow their Instagram anymore
it's just too much you know you don't
need to follow it because like every
time she farts on Instagram like
BuzzFeed writes it up right exactly in
like a positive way and then how to make
fans like hold on guys what's really
going on it's a little closer totally
well justice for Britney seems like it's
finally being served I wish her the best
I hope she enjoys you know all the
herbal teas and holistic remedies that
hopefully they'll be providing her at
this facility yes it's just like when
you say facility so vague you know like
is it you know it's electric shock
therapy or is it a retreat is it kind in
wrench it can meet anything in between I
guess it'll just be like what her or her
family has decided is best for her I
don't think it's electric shock therapy
I think it's more of a Canyon Ranch
promises Malibu sure that's what I think
too but it's just like interesting how
Betty Ford how the word facility like
really can mean so many things and when
how the word facility can
associate confusion no it's like when
people like are shady and like really
send their kids to electric shocker but
like yeah he said summer retreat
facility right like the sisters of quiet
mercy right that's one side right I
don't know if that's still illegal but
electric shocks every is totally illegal
I don't think so Google men our best
friend is electric shock therapy it
might be one of those things that's not
illegal but founder powers like starting
out amazed it is most often used to
treat depression and depression with
psychosis that is not responding to
medication oh okay but it doesn't say
okay still but I mean it in the way it
is legal in the United States though
it's illegal to give it to patients
younger than 16 Oh in Texas in Colorado
well so here's the thing I mean if
electric shock therapy is helping people
with depression then it's great but I'm
talking about the kind that thinks
they're gonna shock the gay out of
people I'm like that's [ __ ] up right
yeah there's this whole Business Insider
article and why electrical inclusive
therapy is more popular than ever that
is it's cuz of Riverdale okay
speaking of Vegas celine dion announces
courage world tour new album in 2019 a
celine dion is ending her Las Vegas
residency soon but the superstar singer
will keep herself busy by releasing new
music and embarking on a new world tour
later this year Dion told a pack then
you wouldn't say that she will kick off
her courage warrant our world tour in
Quebec City Canada on September 18th and
will make stops in more than 50 cities
including Miami la Montreal Chicago and
Brooklyn not New York City I know it's
Barclays Center which is so annoying and
I'm still going either go to the show
anything I was gonna say I see three
opportunities for me to see Celine on
the store okay I see an opportunity in
Brooklyn unfortunately yes I'll be
orange berkland - I see an opportunity
in Newark is that MetLife Stadium
perhaps whatever on my way to seeing her
in Atlantic City I make a pit stop in
Newark and then continuing the drive
straight to Atlantic City I'm definitely
seeing her in Atlantic City
that sounds lit I just I don't
understand this happens on a lot of
tours where they go everywhere around
New York City but not New York City and
they mostly see it on country music
tours no I mean if you're playing
Brooklyn you're technically playing New
York City then you get an offer from MSU
and you get an offer from Barclays
whichever one is better you take like
don't you want to be able to
say I'm playing in New York City yeah
playing Barclays is just as prestigious
and it's the same amenities it's just as
lucrative it's not as prestigious you're
playing an arena in New York I know we
refuse to see it but I don't in some
parts of New York are closer to Brooklyn
than they are to Madison Square Garden I
mean just like they got seen yawns
personal chef you're playing in a New
York borough well
oh she's also playing in Nashville show
maybe I'll see that I'm right I was
thinking maybe I'll go on a trip
somewhere right here but I really also
want to see her in Vegas I thought she
was finishing her biggest residency for
her also just like take a break she's
been through a lot in the past few years
she's not stopped working since she was
young like take a break but no she's now
going on another tour no I think it's
like a talent like hers only comes
around like yeah once in a generation
and I'm I'm glad that she's singing on
tour because so many people need to see
it I mean personally I need to see it
with Brittany and I don't feel that way
because it's like the talent that she
once possessed the dancing the singing
like the river act she know it's no
longer that she's okay yeah lip-synching
to old songs and doing like basic dance
moves the world doesn't need to see it
and you don't need to be doing it yeah
you know I feel like she doesn't even
want to be doing it no it's like funny
I'm holding up the puppet strings and
they're like dance Brittany dance
totally drying anything who is that
person holding the strings I think it's
like her management I don't know but
like how do they think that that is like
the cash is still coming in there has to
be a better way that's we're gonna be
staying in their meetings this morning
there has to be a better way this is
gonna be the break for her Celine Dion
on the other hand she's not taking a
break that's fine with me I just want to
see her I still want to see her in Vegas
I feel like that is also like a
once-in-a-lifetime kind of thing I know
but planning our trip around seeing her
was proving difficult because we
wouldn't also be able to see Lady Gaga
like you have Lady Gaga doesn't come
back until June and Celine ends in June
I really saw you know oh so beaching
Justice League
yeah they're just like running maybe
Johnny and Marie and Monique and Criss
Angel I want to see Monique she does
Vegas she's doing Vegas and what does
she do it so much respect her comedy
uh-huh covet [ __ ] should do it actually
was this morning I watch her Housewives
of New York because I got up early cuz
my phone rang and it had some extra time
and I didn't get to
so housewives in New York last night I
watch it this morning and then my Apple
TV like suggested something and it said
Kevin Hartz on Netflix so I started it
and like was it the apology one
irresponsible tour
oh right where he the one for cheating
on his wife yeah so um it was very
interesting how he got to Sage they put
him in a like a music case like how
people think Taylor script used to
travel in like a luggage thing I just
like I love Kevin Hart and it was like
not good really
yeah I have to watch it because I went
to the actual show at MSG so I think
I've seen this set live so I wonder if
it's just like it didn't come off well
on TV well he just like his delivery was
so weird he like just you know like you
pause wait for people to laugh and like
say the punchline he just like said it
all in one breath and like people would
laugh and then he would move on and
there were something like funny funny
tidbits that if he had like said a part
of the sentence waited for people's
laugh and then said the punchline like
it would've been so much funnier but he
literally just said it all just like
this and then people laughed like it was
weird
hmm watch what it's new thing with you I
feel so very weird to watch a comedy
special at 9:00 in the morning she don't
even yeah you're not in like that comedy
group it's definitely like a mid
afternoon early evening type thing we
never talked about Amy Schumer's yes we
did
no cuz I hadn't seen it Oh what did you
think about it um I had seen like I saw
that special this was like more
pregnancy heavy she had added some new
jokes there were some funny things the
pregnancy stuff was really funny yeah it
was my favorite of yours but also I'm
not pregnant or a mother so I can't I
don't really - all of it you know I mean
I didn't really do it but I still
thought the pregnancy stuff was funny I
didn't even finish the second half
because when she just started talking
about she got arrested and like was
getting all political that's like my
least favorite thing and I was just like
it's something I it's like what's going
on in the world sad like and when she
said that she got arrested I was like
it's I literally talk to myself it's so
crazy she got arrested I don't even
remember like he was she got a DUI I
like right and then I remembered oh she
like walked up to a police I mean can't
a person I know and she said I went
there with the intention of getting
arrested so that doesn't count
not like a societal faux pas where it's
like you have to make a mess right I
think she was saying she was like like
you gotta shake no I know I went there
and lawfully got arrested right right
it's not the same right okay next up
you guys The Game of Thrones Shawn
Johnson is pregnant okay I love her yeah
and she had that YouTube video where the
guy thought they were pregnant and they
were like documenting like the early
stages before they told everyone and
they miscarried and it was I ended up
being the saddest video I just want to
double-check someone wrote that in the
comments
I [ __ ] love her that's really and I
hope that it's true Shawn Johnson east
we cannot wait to welcome you to the
world shower you with love oh my god
they already have an interim the East
baby 15.7 Wow oh my god it Congrats I
wonder how far along they are Wow when
you get pregnant like knock on my god
wailing God willing God willing a
million just have maybe knock on what
God willing will you make an Instagram
percent child I mean I don't know cuz I
think it's like a layman losery but at
the same time like it seems to be
working for everyone else and it may be
think you have one for your dogs which I
think that's technically lamer actually
hey no it's not I mean Theo's is premium
but like dogs technically are like less
important than your babies less
important gate but the dogs alive no
babies I'm alone but okay but say even
when maybe not while it's in utero born
Oh Instagram for your child no because I
think an Instagram like a baby is really
good for your Instagram like it but the
flow right you don't want to like I
don't want to provide the audience I
want the follows and the likes in the
comments right dog that's it baby
I agree that I agree with okay this game
of thrones season 8 premiere last night
the stars turned out dead and alive they
all showed up yeah thought it was so
funny how like most of the people who
everyone was most excited to see like
died years ago
like we're excited to see them because
we haven't seen them in felt when I saw
Ned Stark my jaw hit the floor he was
looking good he had lost a little bit of
weight from the guillotine idea like
sheds a few paths it's definitely a cat
a cardio burner
wait what was so funny it's like also I
couldn't recognize how many people like
Joe Jonas post this picture with him
sophie Turner and this guy and I was
like who the [ __ ] is that
it was Joffrey he looks so different oh
my god I saw that too and heat hashtag
King Joffrey otherwise I would have
thought it was Ramsay I would have
thought it was one of her brothers like
bran or the other one yeah it was very
confused man or man yeah okay
Sean Bean looking fine Kit Harington and
rest restlessly
okay I think I think her name's Rose
Leslie but if it is restlessly no it's
not yes it is
it's Rose Leslie [ __ ] no not where
she's from it's breathlessly okay well
where I'm from she's Rose Leslie and
it's gonna keep it that way
wait I just like I mean I read blinds
about the fact that they think that like
Emilia Clarke and Kit Harington have
this whirlwind romance and Russ Leslie
is just like getting in the way and her
and Emilia Clarke are always hating each
other but the pictures that I saw of
Russ Leslie and Emilia Clarke like you
just can't fake love like that yeah you
know like smiles they'd like each other
then we had zoe kravitz his stepdad yes
I'm sorry crevasses that week hobbits
his mom step out together I didn't mean
like the fat like literally the only
pictures I saw of this event were from
Khal Drogo and him getting out of the
car and everyone screaming like that was
really what the media that I saw most
immediately like he hasn't been on the
show in seven years it's crazy it's
crazy like and people still like ship
him in Daenerys I mean I do if he makes
a return in some way this season like
that's the only way they could top my
wildest dream and they would he would
have to come through in and dream but
then it would be like as a society and
apparently people are still catching up
on Game of Thrones so spoiler alert no
I'm sorry if you're one of the basic
[ __ ] who's now only watching it
because all the boards you know watch it
like sorry
Jackie's been watching since season one
and I've been watching since the day
after season one because I watched the
whole thing and then I've been on the
boat since season two like all these
girl being like oh my god Khaleesi like
drink my wine dragon Oh Michel they're
like lame as [ __ ] and if you're not
caught up now you're just like a bad lag
and Fenning you deserve to have it
spoiled right oh okay so at this point
we all ship Daenerys and chug nephew
Smee chest
Jon Snow yes Daenerys is John and Smee
chest and she's a damn good and hit that
so she's half Targaryen half stark half
something else she's she's at all yes
she's at all so when it when you when
you think like who's gonna get the
kingdom it has to be her you know but
then it's also like Jon Snow defied
death it has to be him but I'm just
gonna say four words no I don't want to
hear you because you're always right
whatever you're about to say I don't
know
[Applause]
stop sorry until you agree to stop
talking are you done
Robert Baratheon are you done yeah
totally look at my hair today do you
think the same character to play Robert
Baratheon that they got to play Hagrid
in nobody was like definitely Hagrid's
on without a doubt I can't wait to start
me copying Game of Thrones our game is
ours recaps are so funny finger and bum
[Music]
should I've really been meaning to catch
up to you watch everything so that I was
like a wealth of knowledge and I guess
at this point I'll have to settle for
just re watching the last season but
don't you think it's interesting in Chad
day better in wha them to premiere
unlike Coachella weekend why because
like everyone's gonna be at Coachella
Coachella we go yeah I'm the we're
leaving in time and I'll just have to
like sleep my way field and check my
phone and then when I'm on Monday I'll
watch it but it's like all those who
like hotel are gonna be on their phones
and they're gonna have it spoiled for
them
Shanee of them to do that to Ariana
Grande maybe in some way it was
intentional like let's think sophie
Turner and Joe Jonas are like the most
immediate like connection today yeah
also like Ariana Grande if they try to
shoot ariana grande Ariana Grande and
Pete Davidson PG VM you take custody of
it
Kenzie David is a daughter of glory I
don't think they're hating the
performers I think they're changing the
concert goers cuz it's like those people
are like the coming oh that's so major
si Khaleesi and it don't real Game of
Thrones fan fans have had that weekend
cleared right and it's like okay now
pick are you gonna be like a Coachella
thirst monster or are you gonna Khaleesi
and just where we're doing both right oh
yeah I don't feel like it a process you
know I'm also like not looking at my
phone right now cuz I feel like people
are like putting legitimate theories out
there and I'm just like I want to be
shocked no but we are putting pictures
in the stream so let's talk about some
of the the notable couples
Joe and Sanchez stepped out looking
filleting and we reported yesterday that
he had to sign an NDA once he found out
at that and you think I'm friend who is
that that party knows the ending yes oh
no cuz I'm sure there were some like
low-level light but the caterers being
like pulling Jojo decided yeah please
tell me how it ends no I don't think the
caterers knew I think there's probably
like some press there being thirsty and
they don't know anything
they're trying to find out I think just
like the the career knows and an Amanda
Peet's husband knows oh yeah man defeats
husband was George RR there I didn't see
any pictures of him I saw a story about
him like eyeing an Iron Throne I think
he was definitely there for sure where
was it it looks like 30 rock it was at
Radio City I don't like that Swank City
it kind of doesn't meet that uh did they
show the episode how do premieres works
I got a movie before do you watch a
movie I think so I think there's a
soiree and a film and the red carpet
some people just do the red carpet some
people do red carpet soiree some people
go to see the movie headed to a premiere
once you did for Bad Santa
- oh and I watched the movie and I ain't
so much popcorn and I had already had a
toothache was the popcorn three yes okay
and the popcorn was getting stuck in my
existing toothache and it was just
really painful and they weren't crop top
so I'm glad that nobody offered to take
my picture
oh well I like your shirt today Itzik
not a [ __ ] bow but it's giving me like
the [ __ ] bow elegance and you know what
am i seven inity you know and I can trim
you - because it's Zac Zac Posen it's
like their diffusion line so it's like
not Zac Posen [ __ ] though like so much
corporate glamour
it's like for children for young and for
children in the business place for yo
pros young professionals for y is in
adults from Millennials truly well you
look cute
thank you back to the task at hand the
game of thrones red carpet oh yeah who
else
Maisie Williams showed up with purple
hair she's highly said emerging the
Kylie Jenner of the Seven Kingdoms
so true looked platens she's like always
described anything other than she's like
being cast aside but her and her crazy
hair like she's gonna end up maybe she's
the one who gets the kingdom I can't
describe anything other than dracarys
when you say jewel chorus you know what
I think
Drakkar no ha the perfume that's funny
emilia clarke wore a dress that like had
writing on it and they literally in
1,000 photos could not figure out for
the life of me what it [ __ ] said oh
I'll have to try this leave your door
open so I might sleep walk in or
something maybe it's a which makes no
goddamn set maybe it's a spoiler oh here
we go
oh yeah I'm not gonna be able to read
that she looked great she always looks
great and like she can really I think
she looks weird she can pull off any
look I don't know if it's cuz she always
looks so happy so
people who look happy it's just an
attraction to the smile um I thought
happiness looks good on you happiness
looks good on everyone I think she looks
great I think she looks so high-fashion
honestly I think the best-dressed of the
night which is so crazy considering her
characters that antithesis of glamour
Brienne of Tarth looked [ __ ] jerk
Aras okay
jus Brienne of Tarth like is constantly
sliding on red carpets and it's actually
quite jarring to see because like I know
Briana's as one thing and that's just
like the Big Friendly Giant and then she
like shows up in like Javon Shay Kuchar
and it's honestly it's confusing for me
okay it's confusing but I feel like the
actress Gwendolyn is glad to be giving
us a psychotic me because it's like
getting you a girl who can do both no
and I'm sure she not thrilled with her
hair and makeup and wardrobe choices on
the show get you a who can kill a man
with her bare hands and slaying Siobhan
Shay and give you a man who like get you
a girl who is like kind of in love with
Jamie you know right because who can
resist the perfect man from the other
woman you know Jamie Lannister is hot
like really hot and it's like hard for
me to forget that he used to [ __ ] his
sister from the back but once you get
past that and just see him for like you
know the good guy that he is I couldn't
even kill the Mad King you know or like
he did but he was turned behind
he didn't kill Brienne of Tarth no he
killed the Mad King but like because the
king was mad and he was telling them to
burn them and burn it all yeah but but
when what was that thing he revealed to
Brienne of Tarth being like I didn't
actually Oh stab it or maybe the Bad's
him in the back and that was like
shameful for him right cuz he was
supposed to be like this great war hero
who did it right in the eyes of the king
right and then it's like Alfie Allen was
there um and it's really hard for me to
separate him from he's the only one who
looks like reek he looks like his
character that is Theon Greyjoy Theo
Greyjoy I see oh great please do not
compare my price he turned out to be a
hero
Theon Greyjoy been through a lot okay
he's been through a lot like lest we not
forget you know the sods uh rape of it
all right the burnt what Cleese boys
right farm Oh terrible terrible which I
think it was Brad but really it was the
farmers sons pretending it was Brandon
there was a butcher's sons
horrible horrible burnt Winterfell to a
Cleese burned those boys to a please
please Sean Johnson just like my comment
ok guide I would she respond it's me
thank ya um anyways Peter Dinklage was
there obviously looking like a cutie he
was also an elf
where was Cersei she looks the most
different from her character because she
well she actually has a pixie cut in
real life but for so long she had long
blonde hair on the show and then in real
life she had a pixie cut back I know
it's crazy
but now she has a pixie cut blonde hair
so it's looking a lot more similar Sarah
Paulson was there but she's competing
you know but it's true all these
characters like out of any show they
look the least like their characters
yeah I know it's when you the first time
that you realize it like the first time
you see them out in the wild it's like
seeing a dog walk on his hind legs it's
shocking but now we're so used to it
like oh they're you know Sophie Turner's
on the cover of Glamour and she's all
okay you just you just ate it I'm so
sorry I hesitated because the [ __ ]
precious man went out of actually I
think the camera moves but he just did
something so precious and just like laid
down like a dog yeah he's three oh great
Joey he deserves the Iron Throne
so do you thank you I have my guilt or
sat on the Iron Throne no you did I did
they had an exhibit for Time Warner
Cable customers only and me and sitch
Wed and I took a picture and I honestly
don't know where it is and I was looking
mad cute I'm it's so funny it's like I
remember that taste so vividly I was in
like the 11th grade and I just like
feeling really bad about myself that day
I was like wearing a shirt that was too
short for my leggings like the top of my
thighs we're looking like chunky as hell
and I think in hindsight you probably
looked right so I just remember like
hating that picture I remember thinking
like my thighs look so huge and now I
look back and I'm like I have body
dysmorphia because I looked amazing like
and I love that picture that was really
interesting we'll talk about size of New
York that's so sad well you have that
picture maybe we'll share with the class
if I can find it it's definitely like a
[ __ ] and signing pictures yes if you
check out our Instagram I finally found
the picture that I checked with Hilary
Duff right as she yelled at me in the
lobby Casino of the Atlantis when I was
in the 11th grade and then it also found
the picture of me and Brooke Hogan very
dark BlackBerry photo obviously another
great photo but documented the moment
nonetheless happy to hear it
amanda peet was there with her husband
Oh them saying oops cute that was just
like a prestigious estimate and I'd love
that they held it in New York and it
didn't cause traffic cuz I don't even
know and that it was going on agreed on
all friends oh I told it everyone on the
patreon but I'd maybe forgot now that I
was heading to a life for a million
things but also to find a new management
and that I think maybe it's time for me
to but have a full female staff of
management's like maybe the men just
weren't cutting it and I did I went with
my god and they went with the full
female staff management team
but I spoke to yesterday one of them was
in town to go to the Game of Thrones
beer and I'm like homegirl like where's
my ticket but I didn't want like my
first act of business with my new maps
but to me like asking for favors
right I agree which 19 next year's
premier oh wait never mind I can't
believe it's gonna end soon like I'm
like glad that it's gonna end because
people are starting to bother me around
it it take the way this app actually
used to be good but now the people who
watch The Bachelor annoy me yeah and
it's the same with Game of Thrones like
all these girls just be like yes I'm
about to call my mic we switched mics
long story I feel so good I love
coughing like when you're sick and you
want to scratch the back of your throat
you ever do this it's like so disgusting
your time but scratch the back of your
throat you could what oh wait just glad
to back your turn with your throw yeah
Anna back of your throat with your
tongue yeah that doesn't feel good I do
this I'm sorry podcasters oh it feels so
good when your skull like I'm like
scratchy ass throat oh now I'm like the
T word who's looking me dead in the eyes
Oh pollution all over this floor right
okay are we can we close the book on
Game of Thrones even I think we're gonna
be talking about it every day until it
premieres I'm only talking about it for
the next eight weeks yeah and honestly
like the show was great but lets me not
forget that like now these people were
really famous like at all and they're
only famous for this one show and good
for Joe Jonas for bringing the show to
the mainstream no I'm saying no but what
I do want to say Joe Jonas because he
found a woman and I don't know I said
this before but it was like after he
died she had to eat and like she moved
on with singing it was like jacket I
love what you're about to sell was he
ever gonna top that like show the number
one supermodel in the world and and
she's like the most sought-after like
woman in the world like actually read
and like and one of the most beautiful
women in the world
she's like Cindy Crawford and so it's
like it can only go downhill for Joe
Jonas
yeah he'll end up with some you know a
low-level musician
but no he ended up with the lady of
Winterfell look honestly better who was
the most eligible woman in the Seven
Kingdoms you know like he like I'm just
so happy for him and so she supports all
of his endeavors which now are exciting
and he gets to support all of hers and
it's like I don't know what's more
exciting yeah like who has it better and
honestly like I just feel like it's so
interesting how like Joe Jonas like gets
ass yeah I mean and I love Joe Jonas
like you think
I thought of him that way I mean I did I
was like in the in the Jonas Brothers
day like he was my my I don't like I
thought he was the hottest most precious
gem man I was Nick scout but so like
when they grew up and like they still
were like famous like you just never
thought of Joe Jonas as like literally
like Matt Damon like yeah he just gets
like the best girls I'm really happy
that like everyone respects him as much
as I do right he even what was it Taylor
Swift Ashley Greene yeah right but right
now we only think of just like Gigi and
Sophie cuz those but he's working his
way up to Sansa Stark he hasn't any he
is he's claiming the throne and you know
as someone who's you know personally
hung out with them on many occasion and
whom I consider close personal friends I
don't know if I'll be embedded sweating
probably not given the fact that I
wasn't amazing agent party but I just
can say you know from firsthand
experience they really aren't good
together and when he dressed up as her
for Halloween everyone at the party
thought that he was Fiona from track oh
my god because I believe the dress that
he got was a Fiona from Shrek and he was
wearing a red ponytail and he looked
like Fiona like when she like when the
sun goes down you know okay so Mike I
love your costume like we're sure it was
like he didn't get it and then someone
was like oh your son said I was like oh
you're a sad side in tune yeah that was
a great costume and then I ended up in
the Today Show like the picture of us oh
that's fun oh good morning about I
forgot which which morning show oh um
okay next story we must switch gears
from Game of Thrones but have no fear we
will be back the top baby names of 2019
so far Oh let's get John John so down
here give her some recommendations name
berries list of top names 2019 chuckle
member named Barry cute that's cute
is in the first quarter of the year with
two surprising new names taking the lead
okay yes you're not gonna guess mature I
think I could give you two clear
sometimes it's influenced by like TV and
movies it is and it's like I feel I
still feel like the Joe Joe no I still
feel like the number one name I feel
like this is top new names cuz there's
no way so many girls are being named
it's definitely it's still Sarah and
Rachel and Abraham yeah but I think it's
it doesn't say new names but I'm just
saying it's definitely new okay because
it was a time like ten years ago this
list had Miley on it right because Miley
was heavily influencing all the kids so
I'm gonna give you a clue as to the
first thing but I think with my clues
you can get me okay what a fun game clue
number one it was a name that was
speculated Kylie would name her daughter
and clue number two Kristen Dody on this
week's episode of Vanderpump rules
Mariposa butterflied posa marry Maria
poza elaborate Posey yes that it's not a
name like sorry Posey is number one
we're going to draw the line between
words and names like okay flower
actually that could be a name but like
you see what I'm saying you don't draw
the line
so notice anything technically it could
be any Posey a charming vintage floral
name that has never ranked among the top
US top 1,000 takes me there it's not a
name top spot for girls so far in 2019
probably because all these people
thought that Kylie was leaving her
daughter Posey losers like Posey and
they got all this [ __ ] embroidered like
I couldn't take it back I feel like I'm
really heavily influenced by celebrities
until it comes to naming my baby like I
would never make my baby and I think
that people like that name their kids
Miley like that's looser I'm sorry like
so like I have had my names picked out
forever like no matter whoever however
famous Jojo see what times like I'm
never gonna become influenced right you
know the name Jojo is cute because it's
a cute nickname like I would name them
something else Joanna
yeah I actually really like that
maturity down okay top five girls names
and then the top five boys names are
worthy number one Posey number two Isla
I like that I like number three olivia
is like the most people wait it's always
on that list and it's like I'm so
jealous I'm totally jealous of all
y'all's bitch's means except why because
my name is actually the most basic of
the four of us I don't even like my name
your name is so beautiful probably
actually really named Claudia between
Olivia Claudia and Margo like I don't
even know which ones my favorite name I
think mine and uh yeah and then Marga I
would really take umbrage with my own
name if I didn't get to be Jackie O like
if my last name didn't start with O and
I was just Jackie like a basic but there
aren't that many people named Jackie yes
there are I would say there's a few that
like in your class yeah no I'm saying
they're just like Jackie is just as
popular in our popular of a name is
Margo in my unique in our world right
now and unique is not good sometimes
Margo oshri was on the cusp of Margo's
yes that's sure you know in like that
few years now like I think it's a lot
more popular
but I just think it's so beautiful and I
think that Jackie is like Jaclyn is
basic name but mine is calm I'm the
French camper jackeline Charlene
chuckling pull a neat Channel a baguette
sushar layabout get me a chair again do
it again
speech on lay-by get me John ley
baguette oui haha okay number four girl
named Aurora beautiful name we bow we
just get th EO cam because he's looking
mad [ __ ] cute Aurora is so fairytale
that's Cinderella's name I'm not in love
with that name I'm not gonna lie and I
know the people listening like might
have the name so I'm trying not to be
mean but like it's just like not my bad
five made I don't like that it like
Mavis Beacon teaches ma e ve yeah no not
for me very grandmother it's like was
anyone ever born Diane or Barbara yeah
they were I gotta talk to Barbara from
Real Housewives New York about that it
was my birth name because Barr was a
name you get white when you get to
through menopause no but like the name
Barbara was try me at the time like
that's honestly no offense Chloe's but
how your name is gonna date like when
the Khloe's of now or 70 21 year olds
are gonna be like you were born Chloe so
true it's all about perception okay one
of the boys went and said you said I'm
gonna forget one Milo cute name do you
think you do you think has anything to
do with Ventimiglia perhaps perhaps to
Jasper cute three Atticus interesting
very British for Theodore shut the [ __ ]
up I mean obviously people have been
heavily influenced by the celebrity that
I dr. Theodore for chairman and his
groundbreaking work totally oh my god
I'm freaking out I just love him so much
I just love him so much
five Asher I guess that's from I had to
get away with murder
oh is it it wasn't even that popular of
a show Posey replaces Olivia the top
girl name for 2018 while Milo takes the
place of Atticus 2018 s number one spot
for boys that's so funny cuz I don't
know anyone named Posey or Atticus at
Posey Atticus you're not sound like a
couple of siblings who are me and like
make out with each other but you're just
not hanging up I hang out with enough
babies that's true actually
or with enough people who have bit us
yeah
exactly okay now they do a little bit of
analysis popular names most likely to
keep succeeding to like age well Olivia
and Jack Wow our mom was really on to
something that's weird
that's crazy claudia has never ridden
this she's never at the souvenir
souvenir just one with the license plate
with your name I think it's better that
way because violet is like it's a
beautiful name and now everyone's
realizing it's beautiful it's like
anything else it's gonna get overplayed
Chloe
totally that's like Kim card kris
kardashian got around it by doing club a
with the two dice top ancient names
Aurora and Atticus okay
leading import names Maeve and Finn Finn
is kind of make you famous cute but not
for a not for a child no a nickname if
your name is Finland vinius men like you
are the reason I left England most
fashionable classic name's Cora and
Theodore oh my [ __ ] god so
fashionable you are so [ __ ]
fashionable new biblical favorites wow
that's not something you hear new
biblical odda
and Asher oh I like Asher now more if
it's biblical yeah there's a lot of good
names in the Bible gives him a little
crabby come at the [ __ ] of Babylon what
was her name Delilah or something uh I
don't know like Helen of Troy yeah
choice good name yeah well if I got
another dog of it named him Troy or Thor
I have my dog name picked out for Thea's
cousin and it's so cute yeah but like
you're not gonna get one cause you were
talking about forever no but maybe when
I move and I have oh hey I discourage me
do do the dog in the building so it is
friendly it is and there's a nice garden
for loosed upon him a gardenia a crystal
garden most eloquent literary name's
ophelia and Silas I'm sorry the name
will philia I have deep problems because
of the Royals because of them what does
that Amanda Bynes movie where her death
the prince what oh what a girl what a
girl once he those two twins that they
throw the sweet 16 for Oh
philia and oh really uh yeah no peach
and pear yeah she is so nice yeah why
did they say it like why they say lice
yeah when they're trying to give her
calm
I don't know they both in wait a subset
life she is so nice
but they say loss yeah totally
I don't know if we should be peached
it's almost as mad as I get but I think
about the fact that my sister named Jim
Anthony he should be Beach impaired for
Halloween that'd be hilarious costumes
get like huge Princess Peach custom and
then we just keep saying she is so lost
we should say everything in unison in
British accent that's a hilarious
costume totally are they done
um I feel like we do top baby names
every time the thing comes out like once
a year somebody said oh so like it comes
out more than once a year this is every
quarter but I find it wildly interesting
like one you know everyone's always
thinking about baby names like for your
own children I know you all have a list
in your notes what are yours I don't
wanna say the moms they won't come true
and I'll have to say they laugh yeah but
you have to say it because if someone
takes it then I think the opposite I
don't want to get any of you ideas and I
don't want my name to become so popular
cuz I said on the number one millennial
morning show that's true um Shayla that
all of a sudden the name that you like
becomes the Barbara in 20 years
yeah exactly but I have some actually I
don't really know I have some ideas
floating around I have some crazy names
that like everyone says I can't name my
child but snow I've loved it for so long
but I'll see I feel like once you have
the baby if the baby names itself up
totally okay season final story because
we you know I think we're a very jewel
heavy show and we're very jewelle having
instagramers we must also discuss the
positive negative the possible negative
side effects okay convey being trigger
seizures
health officials investigate a cigarette
risks US health officials are
investigating whether electronic
cigarettes may trigger seizures and some
people who use the nicotine vaping
devices the FBI said Wednesday it has
reviewed 35 reports of seizures among
each cigarette users mainly in young
people maybe that's what was happening
in Riverdale all the girls were vaping
every time I say baby if you think of a
commercial
vaping is safer than two okay you know
the truth commercial say for that I
never watch TV anymore I only watched
Mac actually that's a good reason why
I'm not on MTV anymore because I don't
have to watch as many of those
commercials they're so annoying there
are puppets talking about anything
please please please
regulators stress it's not yet clear
whether vaping is responsible but they
said their concern and encourage the
public to report information about the
issue okay so this is just a theory so
look out for it that is scary yeah I
feel like I'm overdoing seizures are so
scary
totally so you have to grab the time
over drilling today
check us out later tonight no I got a
coffee Kitchell and I've been feeling
like my cough has to be directly
correlated yeah they should be looking
into that yeah even though like I'm just
sick from being on a plane like 400
times this week and you're the disease
you got when you've been low and playing
too much I think I'm gonna get it
actually the points guy doesn't get it
like maybe I won't yeah the points gonna
Scout Wow
that's like as much as it's a disease
and it's flattering it's flattering
it means you also have money yeah it's
called the Kings disease and also
lottery winners often get gout because
they start eating all this rich food
that they couldn't afford before yeah no
I have the other one I have the one
where you eat too much McDonald's what's
that called
oh yeah diabetes oh yes covered god
forbid anyways um oh he's up and Adam I
think it's time for an interview what do
you say I think it's 2 c1 talking about
what did he watch Real Housewives of New
York
oh we watched it this morning and there
was a lot of dogs and he was really very
active lately
you guys know any correlations between
vaping and seizures feel free to let the
FDA know feel free to let us know that
something on I feel that we should know
especially if you know we're gonna be if
we're gonna be promoting duels in our
Instagram stories we also need to be
promoting the side effects that's just
it
oh so I think we should also be talk
about the fact that a deadly smells like
fire it smells good it doesn't smell
like toast
totally very own brand but we should
remember to perfume that smells like
burnt bread yeah but like in a good way
like a cher Horowitz says you always
gotta have something in the oven yes hi
precious man gift of man beautiful man
lovely man he's being good so Theo did
watch our houses in New York and he
would love to you know have you ask some
questions on it ok I would like to ask
Theo and Theo's mom because I'm
personally interested in your answer
what did you think was the most
interesting part of the episode the
Comber hold on let me think
Oh LuAnn being insane at the restaurant
ok cuz coming off of last week I was
really thinking to myself in like
jorinda is out of control she knows that
she's wrong and she's trying to make
amends but
anyone dare say that she needs to
apologize like she the word apologize is
a trigger for her she would literally
rather like die then just own up to her
[ __ ] and I was thinking she's literally
a child she want to take up in the way
and she know she did something wrong but
she refuses to say ippolit to say sorry
and anyone who even insists that she
should gets thrown out of her house
she's crazy
but then this week LuAnn was being nuts
with the room and Dorinda was being
really as much as she won't apologize
she's moving forward and in the way that
she's moving forward she's being good
and accommodating you know yeah
like trying to be of a good host and
everything for LuAnn and patient and and
you know let's get there to the
restaurant early so she's not waiting
without us like this is this restaurant
of so count I she'll love it
I was totally team during to all episode
and like I mean I love LuAnn she was
dead wrong dead wrong
who cares if you wake up in a green room
I'm sorry like no I didn't understand
the problem with the room because okay
I'm being bratty and I think that
there's a problem with the room that
they're not saying is that it might be
like annum back part of the house where
it's like a little scary but the colors
of the walls and the fish on the walls
who keeps a shame you know sleeping like
it's so mean and at the end of the day
the only reason for people not want to
want to have a room it's like if I was
in a house and everyone's staying
upstairs I'm the only room downstairs
that's scary if it's in the back part of
the house where like there's a side to
her and someone could come her to me
that's scary but complaining about the
take or like literally who cares
literally who cares I thought it was
like I agreed with her and about saving
that room for Bethenny like it's like
she's coming to this trip like she so
doesn't need to Greece and I was crying
sobriety that um that was the grief
counseling degrees counselor like I
literally tears my eyes I thought it was
so sad I was like trying to make up this
morning while watching and I literally
kept crying because like first of all I
didn't know that they broke up and
obviously that's why she's so torn up
she feels guilty like did if she were
there maybe when they were together were
like they didn't take this drastic
measure like do these drugs because he
was depressed about the break-up like
there's so many questions and then when
she was saying she's like I didn't know
my place in the funeral I didn't want to
overstep like the wife dealt with the
morgue and the kids like all the
financials like I just felt like I
didn't have an identity and like that's
so real like she was in this weird like
in turn-up area where they were engaged
broken up but like she was really the
closest to him at that point but she did
get to be a part of the planning right
and then also it's like Dennis's death
took on this like celebrity aspect
because of her and like it was so in the
public and it's like to not feel like
you have an idea
in the funeral procession and you're
bringing all this public attention to a
rock soon you're inspired to be in I
mean those paparazzi pictures of them at
the burial ground where Bethany is
literally it's hysterically crying are
the most awful things ever and the fact
that like we live in a society where
like people say pictures of that there's
someone would pay money for that like
and encourage that sort of behavior is
horrible horrible okay aside from
Luann's fight I thought the most
interesting part of the episode was the
conversation which is like totally and
it's like wait you think they're
grooming that woman to maybe become a
housewife no because she didn't say
anything it was weird and like who like
coolly of a boat in New York City but
the waters brown like there by the way
of all the places he's over like dead
body yeah of all the place you're
cruising over a lot on our SVU crime
scenes of all the places to have a huge
yacht literally the most useless place
is New York there's not even a river
it's like three feet deep it was so
weird to me and I couldn't get a sense
in the temperature because Bethany was
wearing a blanket but Sonia wasn't
wearing sleeves and it looked cold
outside and it's always colder on a boat
it was October is Halloween yeah yeah so
it was cold it was weird and then the
cherry dog show like was sad made me
depressed and it was like that's some
season one [ __ ] where it's like the
women are involved in the charity world
and like they do stupid [ __ ] like it
Susan one Real Housewives of Dallas [ __ ]
a dog fashion show like clean women I
thought I thought we were past this
there was a couple things in the episode
that we're giving me like early seasons
of real house but he loves the flashback
to the first time Ramona ever walked a
carpet right that was [ __ ] hilarious
and there's something about tensley that
is like very sad and very endearing and
then also frustrating like sad and
endearing is like apparently the way she
sees herself is not Hawaii that the rest
of the world sees her which is just so
sad like to feel that way about yourself
but also it's like I wish she could just
know like she's so beautiful yeah and
then also like the way that she feels
this need to get back into society by
putting on like it's like you're back
already but you're the most successful
show all right elegant like the way she
was a socialite back then doesn't really
like exist anymore like that's right
that's what the housewives oh that's
what the housewives are now it's like
local celebrity but what she moved to
Chicago it's like a building a bread no
cuz you're on Real Housewives of New
York that's what you can say right and
until they make real houses of Chicago
she can't move there but it's also like
I think if the relationship was what she
wishes it was she would move in a
heartbeat if she thought Scott was her
future and they were gonna get married
and had kids and all she had to do was
move to Chicago to Chicago and instantly
grammarians came true I think she would
do that
speaking of like making relationships
happen I finished Real Housewives of
Atlanta I did the first part of the
reading error that's this week okay yeah
so I'll caught up and I have a lot of
thoughts okay I've only seen one and a
half episodes so I'm really interesting
that of all the franchises like these
women are like getting their [ __ ]
together career-wise and professionally
wives at a younger age and like I love
being walked like watching Portia like I
love Portia it's like everything is
happening for her right now and I'm just
like I'm so happy for her same for like
Cynthia like I can't lose you got to
drink with Si groans you know it is and
she's by the way oh my god so when I did
Access Hollywood this week um in LA I
was debating with this guy and I was
talking in before and he was talking
about his girlfriend and it was Mike
Hill Cynthia's boyfriend yes here
talking to him yeah and he wasn't coming
to marry her and he said it on the show
he said I'm dating a real housewife and
I'm like who he's like Cynthia Bailey oh
my god you're always on B screen with
her that's really cute yeah but I hadn't
caught up yet to his face like wasn't
imprinted in my mind
did you watch Eva's wedding yeah Eva's
wedding was beautiful but I have so many
thoughts on Eva's financials I mean if
she's really trying to hide then get off
a reality show right I'm saying so I'm
not sure if I'm buying that but demel a
talking about it behind her back was so
mean but that girl Tanya Tanya I can't
[ __ ] stand I hate her I hated her in
flossing in um where were they Japan I
hated her in Japan and she was being so
stupid like they had a plan Nene was
gonna tell Eva and then she goes and
ruins it she was bothering me so much
but Nene's like out of control yes and
no I only saw the one who have episodes
that I didn't see I don't know if you
watched my story but I have a theory
that Marlo Hampton is like you know
invoking me in Rhapsody how Paul is the
manager and he's giving freddie mercury
bad information yeah I feel that way
about Marlo and Nene like I feel like
mean he's obviously going through a lot
she can only talk to so many people and
like Marlo is her close friend and like
Marlo communicates like bad information
to her and like makes everything seem
more 7 days so that like Nene gets riled
up and yes it was very funny in an abler
and it's just especially because she's
feeling that great stuff tiny from the
group because she wants Nene all to
herself like hell but why Marlo has
never been a housewife is confusing to
me
she's the main character of the season I
don't I don't know all the ins and outs
that's why I don't like to speak on
things how you don't really know but
that's just how I feel you should I was
just using because me really interested
as it was so stupid
I'm teeny I was to you but then at the
end okay so let me I'll give you an
explanation that final episode is
Cynthia's party to launch her Seagram's
peach Bellini spritzer and candy shows
up with Kenya Nene and Kenya hate each
other but Kenya and Cynthia are close so
you here seen Cynthia's mics miked and
she says her boyfriend I'm not I'm
supposed to pretend that I didn't know
Kenya was coming so they got all the Sun
mic where kandi and Cynthia were like in
the cahoots to be like kandi brought it
as a nice gesture I didn't know that she
was gonna bring Kenya but they got her
all on mic and they sound so stupid and
then they have this sit down where Nene
is acting so a rash no she was like you
should have told me she was coming and
it's like this is Cynthia's [ __ ]
party regardless if she knew or not like
the fact that you're such a crazy friend
we're like no one you know is allowed to
have friends it's like the fact that
they had to act in cahoots and have this
whole plan is just a testament to how
irrational Nene is and she's been
bothering me this whole scene like I get
that she's going through a lot but like
Gregg's going through a lot also and
like just like the fact that she's like
demanding that everyone be there for her
on every like when you're going through
something like the people who you've
been there for will be there for you but
like you're not really the greatest
friend to everyone and I'm like Annie
nice tan but she's acting so irrational
interesting okay that's why I just I
don't know what the facts so I bet you
the closet like I could just completely
related to that it's like not to get out
of a house my closet is messy like I
don't want anyone in there but okay say
I'm thinking if I had my friends over
and I told them not to go into a closet
but they want to see my closet like I
have some q-tip they go in there fine I
can maybe live with it but if someone
were to go start filming in there and
then the world would see like that's how
I live on my closets worst day I'm
[ __ ] ripping a shirt off I'd rather
be a shirt ripper than a dirty class I
don't totally but apparently there's
some footage where Nene's on top of pork
pregnant Porsche with a belt or
something that's what yeah yeah what
they got on camera wasn't crazy and
there and then that's what they were
saying they were like we get that we
were being annoying and invasive and
like she didn't want us in there we get
it but what happened afterwards is like
not okay oh so that's what I believe
will happen at the Reunion and that's
what I believe all these text messages
screenshots that are being posted on
Instagram are well I saw what Porsche
should
and yes I mean Nene was being mean but
it didn't reveal anything that was new
information yeah yeah but I'm a Nene's
Stan and that's difficult for me yeah
was there anything else on New York we
want to talk about um no I'm still like
net I'm the season - um I can definitely
see how we're building up towards LuAnn
becoming life is all a cabaret because
she is acting like super junior the
berkshires have never really done it for
me either way that they clearly do it
for someone eating except I loved seeing
Dorinda sister oh my when that woman
came out of the car I was like during
the get of her I was like shook and then
he said you're in this sister and
everything was explained I loved I
totally agree
I loved it so you're gonna see I love
seeing her into decorating I was like
dude okay okay guys so uninterested and
it's like clearly they have in their
contract that every season they have to
go to the BerkShares because Bravo just
thinks this is like gold or something um
fine for you guys it doesn't do it for
me no totally it doesn't do it for me um
okay well I'm looking forward to
hopefully better episode now we're
literally being hyenas when they were
laughing about the shark room well
because they literally called him
they called it yeah and I guess the
shark word was like this unspoken thing
until like people said it and then like
eww Cupid stinky something for so long
and then everyone around you says it and
agrees with you like you wanna scream
yeah yeah that was really funny and I
just need I need a rebirth of some sort
pretentiously like I feel like what
she's been trying to do every season
she's been on has become who she used to
be that person doesn't exist anymore
like anywhere and I just I want better
for her I want more for her and why is
her mom like always lingering ya know
her mom is on the show like a little too
much she's no Dee Dee Simmons like oh
she's know like so me - tensley
that's why Tinsley like has obviously
like she's no mrs. Menil Patton's mom no
she's not like this thing that
everyone's trying to make her into I
don't like her I don't like her either
and she's just like always making
intensely uncomfortable what we need is
for tensley to come out of her shell a
totally step off
toto step off Dale step off don't i'm
wednesday l was like standing there
waiting for him I'm gonna say hi to her
it's like Ramona he's a beast like she's
not gonna say hi to you have you guys
even met like right I can't
anyway just sneezed these things what a
great hair for our interview yes so we
will be gonna really our key change
tomorrow and then we're gonna be
releasing it as tomorrow's episode yes
we are predicting we're gonna be
hungover from our one year anniversary
party tonight we just wanted to prepare
so the Erika Jayne special extravaganza
will be released on iTunes tomorrow
morning so make sure to subscribe to our
podcast on Spotify on iTunes on stitcher
on all the places and then make sure to
subscribe to the live show we're the
morning toast we go live Monday through
Friday 10:30 a.m. Eastern Time on
YouTube so subscribe I'm grown with no
job heading to Clearwater and Orlando
Florida this weekend so please head to
girls no job dot-com to grab ticket
I'm Jackie ashtray at Jackie O problems
heading to post premium content on my
Instagram channel where you should
follow me and my nephew sneetches at pub
within a drop because these premium as
well bye
you